Sí.
Un quantum circuit va a ser la unidad de valor
para tu negocio; el qubit es la unidad de información,
pero un circuit es la unidad de cómputo.
Así que tratemos de entender qué es un quantum circuit
y veamos su anatomía.
Esto es cómo se ve un quantum circuit:
se compone de distintas partes. Los qubits
están representados por estas líneas horizontales; en este caso estamos mostrando
un circuit que tiene cuatro qubits, como puedes ver
aquí. Ahora bien, los gates son
cómo controlamos los qubits,
y los lees de izquierda a derecha.
Los gates de un solo qubit pueden ser de un
solo qubit o de múltiples qubits.
Ahí ves el gate controlado:
es el que tiene la línea entre dos de los qubits,
y ahí es donde va a ocurrir la operación de entrelazamiento.
Y por último tienes la medición y la salida clásica.
Y algo muy importante: ejecutas un circuit muchas veces
para obtener el resultado, con la noción de shots.
Un contador de shots es el número de veces
que tienes que repetir un cómputo para obtener el resultado.
Bueno,
¿cómo se ven?
Veamos cómo es un circuit de dos bits,
como la imagen que mostré antes, que introduce un cambio de fase.
Y antes mostré una operación que realizaba esa rotación
que permite llevar a cabo esa operación de interferencia.
Entonces hagamos una comparación entre un circuit clásico
y un quantum circuit. En un circuit clásico
lo que verás es que no aparecen lunas azules,
no hay rotaciones, todo aquí es rosa,
y tienes los estados individuales.
En esos gates solo se veían ventanas esféricas,
pero fíjate en el contraste que hay
cuando realmente implementamos un quantum circuit:
estos son los circuits reales que ejecutamos en nuestras computadoras cuánticas,
que tú también puedes probar.
Los circuits que vamos a crear
con la combinación de los gates
generan la amplitud compleja completa,
la imagen que te compartí
antes. ¿Por qué es importante eso?
Porque ahora podemos generar estas relaciones complejas
entre los qubits en términos de fases
y entrelazamiento, y luego, mediante el acto de la medición,
somos capaces de colapsar esta enorme cantidad
de cómputo que está ocurriendo internamente en
alguna respuesta importante.
Y así es como llegamos finalmente
a la respuesta. Si los ponemos lado a lado, solo visualmente,
puedes tener una idea de que un circuit clásico nunca puede
explotar el vasto espacio computacional
que puede aprovechar un quantum circuit. Es
lo mejor que puedo darte para esta intuición
de la riqueza con la que podemos acceder a este gran espacio de estados.
Y lo hermoso de esto es que podemos
tener muchas clases de circuits para
realizar distintas funciones. Así que,
por ejemplo, este es un circuit
diseñado para modelar riesgo financiero.
Este es un ejemplo de un circuit
usado para buscar y optimizar problemas.
Y este es un ejemplo de un circuit que se usa para
simular una molécula. Una conclusión
importante es que puedes diseñar distintos circuits
para distintas aplicaciones.
Los circuits que diseñamos se capturan
en software y se guardan como software,
y en nuestro caso los guardamos en Qiskit,
que es nuestro kit de desarrollo de código abierto para computación cuántica.
Este es uno de los frameworks de software
más utilizados para computación cuántica.
Y puedes imaginarte construir
bibliotecas de circuits que se integren en
programas clásicos que ahora combinan lo mejor de la programación clásica
y lo mejor del poder cuántico.